Mary is with us in Cincinnati hi Mary
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you I okay so we I found your show
stumbled across it and then my husband
lost his job so you know I don't know
everything there is to know yet but he
was with them for a long time several
several years so he's getting a pretty
decent severance pay they laid him off
she was getting a pretty decent
severance check and my question is
should we pay off some of the debts that
we can you know eliminate so that we can
get rid of some monthly payments laid
off
well a couple months ago he's been
unemployed for months well no they gave
him $60 60 days of paid you know they
paid him for an extra 60 days and then
the summer's check is coming on the
eighth and so he he's been applying for
jobs and stuff in the meantime he hasn't
found anything yet but the pain how long
has he been looking for work for two
months ever since he got laid off Wow
honey I don't have anything in two
months no well he had surgery and other
beasts it's a long story but yeah no he
hasn't
okay how long was he at that job twelve
and a half years what's he do well he
does technicals one it was a technical
support job for a cable company and he
is trying to get into IT but he doesn't
have any certifications because he
didn't need them to do what he was doing
well because he worked his way up and
yeah I don't know does that make sense
yeah what did he used to make twenty to
thirty nine an hour
and what did he make in a year on
average well I think technically he made
40 to 1,000 or so but we didn't get that
because we have a we have a daughter
with cerebral palsy and so we had to he
had to take a lot of unpaid FMLA so I
think we were getting more like maybe
36,000 or much little severance well he
hasn't gotten it yet but I it it's a
week's worth of paper every time so we
figure with taxes and stuff we'll
probably be between eight and nine
thousand okay no you should not pay off
any debt and yes he needs to get
re-employed in 20 minutes doing
something doing something okay after 12
years of doing one thing he is and he's
been through some medical issues too
he's a little bit emotionally back on
his heels he kind of got knocked down
mm-hmm and he's not feeling real great
emotionally right now right they got
knocked out of the saddle you know what
I'm saying
so you and me our job is get John win
back in the saddle here because he he
needs to get back after it as fast as he
can he's not got a lot of money room to
grieve this he's going to have to get
with it yesterday the faster he gets a
job the more this money is a signing
bonus for the next job if you burn
through this money while he sits around
and sucks his thumb and whines about the
man laid him out for after 12 years and
life's not fair you're gonna burn
through this money you're having none of
this money to do anything with because
you used it for his emotional recovery
no pain we're gonna get after it get
after it get back in the saddle get them
right now this is a hottest job market
in 30 years in America right now it is
easier to get hired right now that in
any time in the last 30 years you can't
get a job right now in 20 minutes some
zop now maybe he needs to get the
certifications but he can go do that at
night after he gets his job mm-hmm so
just get a job doing something get a job
too he wasn't making that much to start
with I mean but let's get after it and
then what that does is you making some
money you can feed the family it frees
up this nine thousand to start hitting
some of your financial goals which one
of those goals would be I would take
some of that money and go get those
certifications mm-hmm
I would do that but don't go get this
money and sit on your butt and go get
the certifications go make some money
okay now hustle grind hustle grind
that's what he's got to do I got to tell
you when someone comes into your office
arc walks into your workspaces that's it
you're done if you have a pile of money
called an emergency fund and you have no
debt you know what your first question
ought to be great how much is the
severance because that gives you
opportunity to go look for a job and
make more than you used to make not less
and you wouldn't have been out there
looking for an opportunity to make more
if they didn't boot you out the door
Eagles fly because the mother Eagle
kicks them out of the nest and they
either gonna hit the ground or they
spread their wings sometimes getting
laid off from a job you're stuck in is
the biggest blessing that ever happened
in your life but you have to set your
mind that way you have to wrap your
brain around the idea that every time I
get laid off it means I get the chance
to make more money not less have a
better job a more fulfilling career work
with better people not less that's a
mindset that's a decision but human
nature is we don't like rejection well
I'm the same way I don't like rejection
nobody does nobody likes after I've been
here 30 years and then they walk in and
go you basically ugly hit the door that
is just that's rejection
talk to a lady last hour 24 years of
marriage two months out of a divorce its
rejection but who knows maybe she'll
marry a better guy this time around at
least she knows what not to pick right
but rejection says oh you got a settled
you're not worthy and those voices start
playing in your head from that teacher
that was a jerk or that parent that was
a jerk or whoever it was it was a jerk
that told you you weren't worthy and you
weren't good and you weren't gonna make
it
we've all got them those voices they
those tapes play in your brain man and
you just gotta look up uh-huh no no no I
can do all things through Christ who
strengthens me I can do I can do all I
am NOT a victim and but it's you know
what that requires it doesn't require
some superhuman strength it just says
you know what I think I can make more
than $36,000 a year how many times have
you heard a success story of someone in
ordinate ly successful because they got
booted out of something and they got mad
and their revenge was success you ever
hear of Mary Kay Cosmetics that's her
story she became a multi gazillionaire
because she was a 50-something your old
lady and got fired from a horrible job
it was the one most wonderful thing that
ever happened to her in her life it's a
great story you ought to read it there's
stories like that all over the place
maybe that's your story maybe you get
ken Coleman's book proximity principal
and you get in the proximity of someone
and something where the thing you want
to do that pays three times what you
used to make
and you go yeah I'm thinking the best
revenge is success I had a guy fire me
off a radio station one time he said
Dave your show so boring someone's gonna
wreck in their car after they fall
asleep and I'm gonna get sued he's not
in radio anymore I'm on 600 stations